- Nowadays, I smoke about a pack a month.
- I smoke two packs a day.
- If I'm working both
jobs in the same day,
then it can be like three or four.
If I'm drinking, then like five or six.
- Been smoking since I
was probably fifteen?
- I started smoking
because I was in a play.
My excuse was method acting, but deep down
I really wanted to just
try smoking cigarettes.
- I went to college and started drinking
and just had an occasional cigarette
while drinking and it took me here.
- I know smoking's bad for me.
It's probably something that I
want to quit eventually but it's
a lot easier said than done.
- [Meredith] I've quit for, a
few times, a couple weeks tops
and then end up just buying a pack again.
- [Edd] I hope to get scared out of
smoking cigarettes anymore, and finally
be able to fully quit.
- [Meredith] I'm upset with myself
that I have decided to pick up this habit
and hopefully seeing the physical
changes to my face, it'll help me
make a positive choice in
my life to quit smoking.
- I don't think it'll change my mind,
but it's worth giving it a shot.
(sigh)
- Aww!
- Oh my god.
- Oh shit, oh wow, ahh.
- I'm so old.
- The craziest part about
it is it doesn't look like
I have makeup on, it just
looks like I'm an old man.
- Ah, that's awful.
- [Meredith] Lines
around the lips will make
my lipstick bleed, and I
do like to wear lipstick.
- [Edd] The looseness of the skin gives it
a very almost frail texture.
- [Michael] Well my teeth
are absolutely disgusting
and I'm kind of taken
back, it's pretty bizarre.
- If this is what my outside appearance
looks like, just from smoking cigarettes,
then I cannot even imagine
what my insides look like.
- It's kinda depressing, I just, I feel
like I'm an old man.
- After this experience, I definitely
want to cut cigarettes
out of my life completely.
- I don't want to continue smoking.
- I'm going to reconsider
smoking less or quitting.
- Try to make sure that my body
ages naturally and not super-advanced
like this process shows.
- A lot of people say they only smoke
when they're drinking alcohol, and
that's exactly how I started doing it.
It can turn into a habit
that you do every day.
- I still kind of really want a cigarette,
which is how upsetting of a hold
cigarettes can have on your life.
- It's not worth it.